[Music]
[Applause]
Lions radio analyst former pro bowl
offensive tackle also picked up a Super
Bowl ring with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
Lomas Brown joining us on the program
Lomas good to see you you look great
um I'm worried about the hype
I'm worried about the expectations it's
been a while since the Lions have had
these kind of expectations so
uh what's your thought going into
tomorrow night about this team
yeah Dan I tell everybody I'm sipping
the Kool-Aid right now I'm not guzzling
the Kool-Aid I'm just sipping it right
now you are so right my good man it's
been such a long time since the
expectations have been hot like they are
around here in Detroit the fan base is
ready we think the team is ready to go
up there and face the Kansas City team
which we all know they're they're one of
the best teams in this league each and
every year so we're hoping that this
hike train that we've got a lot of
people on the hike train right now so
hopefully we'll be able to keep them on
the train and won't lose any passengers
okay what's your biggest concern about
the Lions this season
so my my biggest biggest concern with
the Lions right now is our defense
that's been my biggest thing we know
what the offense can do it's the
defensive side of the ball we know where
we finished that last year and towards
the end of the season we became a better
defense but still finishing the you know
towards the bottom of the pack that's
just not going to get it done we had too
many shootouts last year that we tried
to win and we couldn't win so hopefully
this year we won't be in as many close
games hopefully the defense will be able
to step up uh some good uh service for
the offense how confident are you and
Jared Goff
very confident in Jared I mean Man Dan
just to see him from when he first got
here to the confidence level he has now
you should see him he walks around he
got a little tested a little air in his
chest and I like that because he's a zoo
in that confidence to the team the rest
of the guys feed off of that so I think
Jared has been a godsend and I think he
set this stuff up to be the quarterback
for the Lions for a long time
the Lions draft strategy was a little
confusing because teams don't value
running backs so what they do they draft
a running back and then teams don't
value middle linebackers and then they
get a linebacker here uh how would you
rank the draft now a few months later
well it was shocking you're right when
we picked Jamir Gibbs but
kind of trying to pick the mind of Ben
Johnson our offensive coordinator a
creative guy that he he man look damn
this is the same man that put an
offensive tackle in motion on third down
and actually through the pass to him on
third down in the actual game so you
know the sky's the limit for Ben Johnson
I'm just I just want to see what he's
going to be able to do with a Jamir
Gibbs because he could put this guy all
over the field and to be honest with you
Jack Campbell the linebacker I've been
pleasantly surprised I really have been
he's a big guy man six five about 250 in
there and that's a long guy he has great
range in the middle so I want to
continuously see him get better and
better even though he's a rookie I think
he's going to play a lot for the Lions
this year he's Loomis Brown he works for
the Lions the radio analyst former
All-Pro tackle there what's your
favorite Barry Sanders story
look
you you it's almost like a stray you
know when you see the Stray every time
you turn around they're back at your
house that's how Barry was I fed them
once or twice and every time I would
turn around Dan I would get that knock
at the door and that's a little fella
the little big fella standing at my door
ready to get a meal so that's him if you
if you're limited with your food
consumption or your food bill don't
invite Barry Sanders over because he
will eat you out of the house and home
wait wait so your favorite story is not
him running with the football it's him
showing up at your house wanting food
he's eating all my food and then he
would show up already eaten so he would
already have something he's eating and
still show up at your house to eat yes
sir that's my favorite story of the
little big fella If he if he had stayed
playing
would he be the all-time rushing leader
easily easily I mean Walter Payton's
record was writing writer's Striking
Distance for Barry but that's how
Barry's been his whole career even when
he got back in 1989 Barry was never
motivated by money uh never motivated by
recognition that those things never
motivated him so Walter Payton's record
was something that was an afterthought
to him making more money in this league
was an afterthought Barry was more
concerned with his help getting out
healthy and being able to uh live or
predict productive life his agent called
me I was at SportsCenter he said Barry
is going to retire he's going to London
he's going to be on a flight but you
can't tell anybody
what was your reaction when you found
out that Barry was gonna and I think he
rushed for 1500 yards that season and
then oh yeah walked away
absolutely Dan I was I wasn't surprised
when he walked away I knew he was
he went back a lot of the people kept
thinking oh
oh I'm back he's gone
Barry is a guy strong to his convictions
when he says something he's going to do
it he's going to follow through with it
so once he retired I knew he was done
with the game everybody say oh go for
the record everybody said this and that
but it was something like I say that
never motivated Barry so once he made
his mind up Dan I knew it was a wrap
back in 1999 when he retired did you
block Reggie White at any point in your
career oh my goodness I'm so happy he
was over the right tackle I didn't have
to deal the only time I dealt with
Reggie White was at the Pro Bowl when I
went to the right tackle position you
talking about the man amongst boys yeah
that's who Reggie White was oh my God
who made you more nervous though Reggie
White or Lawrence Taylor LT there that
was a long week of preparation there it
was a long week getting ready for LT I
mean you remember the famous video we
got to get him a get after them like a
wild pack of dog man that runs through
your mind all weekend long him snapping
Joe first
leg oh my God the dude was just he was
an animal and didn't talk a lot of noise
on the field dad he was relatively quiet
on the field I guess he led his play
through all the Talking form have fun
tomorrow night good to see you low you
look great and uh I hope the lions live
up to the expectations I don't know what
that is I thought it would be make make
the playoffs win at least a playoff game
and I think that would be living up to
the hype is that a fair bar to have for
the Lions that's very fair that's what
we expect we haven't won the uh playoff
game since 1991 haven't won the division
since 1993. I think that's a fair
expectation of these fans for the Lions
to win the division this year good to
talk to you again thank you Lomas take
care of my good man hello Miss Brown
Lions radio analyst and uh former pro
bowl lineman what was it seven
consecutive Pro bowls yep